all right let's go before playing
international master from the hallway I
think it's Norway right the m
hummingbird not sure if I know him don't
think I played him doesn't have a name
that doesn't have a name in them okay
already twenty seconds down there usual
stuff checking out whose opponent and
while getting used to doing commentary
yeah we got this pretty sharp line and
the groom felled see if I would know he
six don't remember okay
really forgot the museum okay we'll be a
few tactics anyway soon so yeah White
has been very cookie on the edge from so
Jesus is now already hard to cover
okay he actually took them well let's
have a look they're actually there more
than one possible moves of course I can
just take yeah but this also shouldn't
be too bad
let's have Queenie force a possible move
attacking a eight and a six man yeah
this is also move to consider
Luke 8 7 and I can just take here okay
now we don't want to lose some time on
move 20 so okay he's immediately sucking
the exchange here but I can I can also
take on h7 now this looks dangerous
thing is some I don't I don't need to
take the rook immediately for instance
if you place King f7 or something now I
have Bishop h6 also threatening the
Queen h8 the Sun I can also play Queen
h8 immediately take d8 at the end but
does it looks dangerous doesn't it
[Music]
okay no interesting I can take here
which jump it's not too bad so win the
Queen of Queen edge aid let's grab the
Queen I shouldn't have any anything
resembling compensation here
yeah okay some
go to h8 now it's completion g7 I don't
know who catches em okay okay then this
is fine still has got the rook hanging
of course
let's do a quick body count what's uh
it's got two minor pieces for the Queen
and everything hanging so okay I grab
this one okay I'm just guessing I think
basically I removed wind snow is just a
huge material advantage and he cannot be
worth much all this stuff is cannot lose
the night Luke the eight on the bishop
because d7 is hanging so should just
just be a winning position not sure
actually why why it's not resigning but
check check check check
hmm okay well so he doesn't resign okay
I shouldn't take f7 no check check check
mate yeah this was some pretty
straightforward window right after you
right out of the opening not sure
well at least rook takes f3 is not
working
thank God maybe he just needs to play on
Knight to f6 and then play this position
it's of course very messy no idea what's
what's going on there blacks King
position doesn't really look very
reliable but it's of course very messy
we might play on something on the Queen
side later
I'll try Bishop d7 and put something on
d5 him well I like white but but this
one wasn't working right man this is
just just easy I think
yeah the combo ready is on +6 let's just
check quickly what what the computer
gives a thing Knight f6 should should
stop okay yeah this is pretty equal
according to to the computer yeah black
needs to play this not much choice
okay next game coming up